ああああああ
[音楽]
ni
dea
[拍手]
[音楽]
me
どうもこんにちは
今動画見て頂きましてどう思いました
とっても素敵な動画4は思われませんでしたか
実はですね
この動画
ある私達夢新聞の活動に共感してくれている先生
この先生がですね卒業前の6年生のクラスを受け持ってたんです
その卒業直前に夢新聞の教室を自分のクラスの子たちと一緒に行ってくれた時の映像
だったんです
夢新聞というのですね新聞づくりを通してという形で聞こえますというとも実際新聞
づくりというとどんな金を抱いた嫌な顔するものなんです
でも今の動画を観ていただいたときに思っ思われたのはとても笑顔
みんなすごい素敵な笑顔だったと思われたんではないでしょうか
実際
夢を描くことによってワクワク楽しくなるそんな気持ちがねあの映像から見て取れたの
ではないかと思います
はい
ところで夢なんですけれども皆さん最近
どなたかとお話しされたことってありますかねえ
たとえば家族の方とかまたは友達とか
夢について語った事って最近どうでしょう
ちょっと考えてみてください
昨日語ったよとか今日来るで語ったようなってことはあんまりいないと思います
でもどの人でも必ず
小さな時小学生のくらいの時には一人一人
いろんな夢をね持ってたと思います
どうでしょうか
でも大人になるにつれて年を重ねるにつれて少しずつ少しずつ
夢というものを忘れて来
5のかいつの頃からか夢は叶わ君がかなわなくなってしまうんじゃないかな
そんな風に
思っている方がほとんどになっています
これはだぜかなと自分なりに考えたんですけれども
学校では
夢を
叶える方法というのはなかなか教えてくれません
じゃあその叶える方法が分かっていたらひょっとしたら皆さんの小さな時の夢っていう
のは今現実になっているかもしれません
僕はですね夢新聞の活動を通してすごく子供たちから教えてやられた事をですね
今日みなさんにシェアしたいと思います
まずの夢新聞なんですけどもこの会社の方ってどれ位の方ご存知ですかね
あの文字知ってるって方いたら手を挙げていただきたいんですけれども
すごい全員ですねあその後たいですね半数ぐらいが夢醜聞ご存知でありがとうござい
ます
ゆレシーブちょっと説明させていただきます
よ親父ってなぁにってことなんですけれども実際夢新聞というのはですね
未来の
これから起こるであろう叶うであろう夢が叶った日付の新聞を今今日現在この手で作っ
てしまおうという
そういった活動です
当然夢後先の出来事ですから内々になりたいとかっていう風にね思いがちなんですけど
もこれをなったという断言した状態で有名新聞を作っていきます
今までいろんなところで mc 分作ってきました
例えばですね
1年生が6年生の高集めた
課外授業であったりだとかまたスポーツ少年団のような所のスポーツチームであったり
長野県といえばですねシニア大学なんかでもシリアの方に向かって
夢新聞の活動をさせてもらってます
こちら
上田市にあります上田演じるというチャーリーリーグのチームです
9チームでも夢新聞をのですね
変えていただくような機会がありました
とってもね素敵な夢を追いが戦でちょっとご紹介させてください
こちら
usap 文字がねあちらこちらにあるわけですけれども
この usa の意味はまた後で
お話したいと思います
今まで長野県だけじゃなくて全国いろんなところで目新聞の活動させていただきました
今日現在でですね全国でああ
52002枚岩井5200人の人が夢新聞の活動に賛同していただきまして先ほどの夢
新聞を描いてくれた
数になります
そういった全国でいろんな方どう接していろんな夢を見てきた僕たちそしてそこで
みんなが
取り組んだことによってすごく気づいたものが僕自身あったんですね
それは何かと言いますと
夢を叶える3つの力この三つの力に僕はすごく気づいてしまいました
この三つの力を学校で教えてもらっていたらひょっとしたら夢が叶ったじゃないかな
となおに思っているんですねですから今日この三つの力を今日来た会場の皆さんに持っ
て帰っていただきまして
夢を叶えて片方ていただきたいなと思います
では実際目新聞
どういったものなのかこの細かにちょっと説明させてください
こちら
ある6年生の男の子が描いた夢新聞です
見出しの部分にね何が書かれているかといいますと
に100歳まで生きた男って書かれてるんですね
どうでしょう皆さん
に100歳までは生きたくないかもしれませんけどもちょっとなナイキはしたくない
ですか
この後はですに100歳までなかなか人類だして内に100歳の
だったという夢を描いてくれてあげるんですけども実際
その時に
どういうふうに人が進化しているかというテーマで書いてくれました
正直僕はこの道見た時ですねに100歳まで生きたとしてもこの格好になってまでに
100歳まで生きたいだと思わなかったです
ちょっと見てみましょうなぜてにね大根があったりとか
人時が出てるんですねもう自給自足です
しかもね息エコなんですもう車はいらなくなりますから
足がタイヤになっています
本当に面白い夢ですでも
このか真剣に考えてこうなっていくではないか
決してね夢の夢はねあの人それぞれいろいろありますけれども
あの良い悪いではないと思うんですね今その夢を描いたときにどれだけワクワクするか
楽しめるかということだと思います
はいじゃあもうちょっとこの先ほどねに100歳まで生き男の夢を新聞を見ながらここ
ところマーカーに説明しています
まず上に新聞ですから日付帰りますちょっとすれば見づらいんですけども
この機付の部分には何が入るかと言いますと書いた秘境かいた時だとしたら今日の日付
ではなくてこれから
金具予定の日付ですね叶った日の日付を入れます
そしてその下にこちらです新聞理由見出し
大きな柱に当たるところですこれは
こちらにありますように何何なりたい
よくね美容師さんになりたいんだという意見があったりとかパティシエになりたいなっ
ていう夢聞きます
そうではなくてもうすでになっている状態丸前になった
パティシエになったというような形の未来の出来事ですけども
完了形で確保
そしてこちら先ほどの200歳の男の日がありますけれども
自分が夢をかなった時のワクワクしている時の様子をですね
自分の手で書きます新聞で言うならば写真の部分にはであるあたります
そして
こちらの破格四角く囲ってあるところに文章を書くわけなんですけれどもこの文章も夢
が叶うまでの異論がストーリーがあります
大変なことやね勉強したことだとかいろんな物語は人それぞれあるわけですそれを
事細かにかけます
そして
夢というのは一人で叶えることはできません必ず誰かの方縁があって
なしているものなんですね
ですからその応援車一体誰なのかそれを明確にイメージしてもらいましてその人が
どんな風に喜んでいるのかそういったことまで文書にしてまとめて1枚の新聞になり
ます
これが夢 c 分です
そうなるとですね普通の新聞ですと子供たちは書きたくないんですけども自分の夢を
描けるとなるとね
こちら見てください
物凄い集中してですね笑顔で楽しくなってワクワクしたなぁ書くんですね
そして嬉しい分僕たち
講師がですね始めるときに必ず
みんなみんなに打つことがありますそれは何かと言いますと
夢新聞を変えたからといって
夢が叶うそういった便利なツールではないんだよということだけを伝えます
でも夢新聞を作ることによってみんなで協力し合うとか
自分の強みを生かすとかまたは
など
助け合う中ですですかねもう一度が困っているところを自分の力で助けてあげる
そういったことをまだ分そういったような内容になっています
ではそれを出すって事例を交えながら具体的に説明していきたいとおもいます
まず夢新聞なんですけれども実際我々講師というのは
生徒さん達だとか受講者に対して一切の作り方の指導をしません
1枚の
夢新聞の書き方もツールだけを渡します
私たちがいうのはこれですね何時何分まで
クラス全員で誰も見捨てずに全員で掻きあげましょう
ということだけしか言いません
これを達成するためにではあれあれば
たとえ席を立ってもらっても構いませんしまたはの友達の特に気に入っても構いません
教科書を広げてもらっても辞書を広げてもらってもいいわけなんですね
何をしても構いませんまったく自由にやってもらってます
ただしその代わり我々だとかまたお父さんお母さんが見学に来ている場合にはそういう
人たちは絶対
質問しても答えてくれないよそれだけしか言いません
こうなるともうとなって即不安がって来ちゃうんですね
なぜかと言いますと子どもたちは自由に暮らす歩きもあります
友達のところに行って質問して話し合ったりします
それを傍から見てる音がなからするとですねどうしても遊んでるんしか見えないんです
時にはこんなクラスもあります
お祭り騒ぎですねもう
クラッシュみんながある気もあるこれを遠くで見ている親はどんな思いをするか
こちらのお母さんなんですけれども自分の子供がですね
あんまりこう動かないんです他の過去を動くわけですね
その他離島
ここね見ながら後ろからあんた配布
はい動きなさいよ聞こえるように指示命令をしちゃうんです
どうですか皆さんもし自分のお子さんが
ね体からじゃぁ後小倉そんな走り回ったりとか
または他の人たちがみんな一生懸命やってるところポツンと座ってるだけだったら
すごく
読者のかな大丈夫かなっていうそんな気持ちになると思います
僕も実際息子がいます
息子はもしこういった状況であれば凄く不安になります
でもそれっと不安というのは何なのかっていうとすべては自分が自分がなんですね
自分をよく見せたい時はために不安になってるだけなんです
でも子どもたち
はですねすごく先ほどは私が入った三つの力を常に持ってますから
自由に自分たちで解決しからする力を持っています
当然大人から見ると遊んでる主が見えません
ですが子どもたちは自分なりに自分の持っている力をすべて生かしてミッションを達成
していくわけなんですね
例えばこちらなんですけれども
おど真ん中に育っている水色の服着た女の子なんです
このこの女の子はですねこう夢真も各にすごく困っていたわけです
それをするとその目の前にいるピンク色の服を着た
この子ですねこの馬
突然駆け寄っていってどうしたの
私のわかることがあればって言うんですけども小さい
小さい子なんですですからなかなか指導というか教えるって言うことができなかった
です
そしたらこの子がとった行動というのはですね自分のおねえちゃんを連れていっ
そしてペズだってあげてください手伝ってって言う
自分にはできないけど自分のお姉ちゃんされていくことによって困ってるを助けること
ができる
そんな風に助け合いおこう自然とで子どもたちはしちゃうんですね
これって凄いと思いません
大人一切何も言ってないんですよ
もう3すべて子どもたちが自分の判断自分の考えで行動を取っています
またこちらの男の子
このかですね文章書くのが非常に苦手なんです
そうな時にこの2人のお友達は
駆けつけて
文章を書けないんだったら俺が考えてやるからその通り
文書かけだ
っていう音でず去ってくれるんです
これも大人は一切団にも指示命令一切してません
でこの男の子文書仕上げるわけです
でもこの男の子はですね特にあるんですね何かといいますと
非常に絵を描くのがすごく上手なんです
クラスの中に絵の描けない子がやっぱり一人や二人いるわけなんですがその子のところ
に行って
今度は僕が力になる番だという風に
助けを助けているわけですね
本当に子供たちすごいです
大人は一切ジャッジをしなくても自分たちで何をすればいいかも全て分かってますし
どう行動すればいいかということが全てもうわかってるんですね
巨根な子達から僕自身がすごく学んだ3つの力ということで皆さんにボって書いて
いただきたいのはこちらなんですけれども
一人一人の思いを実現する一番良い方法というのはですね
みんなが自分の強み自分の特技ですねこれを生かして自分から助けに行くように自ら
働きかけ
そしてね葬式みんな何が他のチームに入っています
小チーム全員体勝ち抜こうぜっていうことを
タイデー
入っています
これもうちょっと細かく言いますとこんな形です千々町任命ではなくて一歩踏み出す力
これも当然
マニュアル人間なくて考え抜く力
個の力も当然
一匹狼じゃなくてね自分だけ良ければいいんじゃなくてチーム全体で
働く力これ見つけ妖精ということを話しています
今日ぜひこの3つをですね皆さんに持って帰っていただきたいなと思います
では先ほどの冒頭でお話した
ちゃーりーでぃんぐ上田エンジェルスのですね usa の
こちら usa とありますがこれどうなったかという話をちょっとしていきます
上田演説たんですけども
34年ぐらい前ですねあのーみんなに支えてもらいました
を先ほどの usa た何かと言いますと世界大会に出場するとみんなで書いたんです
ね
で世界大会に出る前には日本の全国大会優勝しなければいけません
その結果どうなったかと言いますねこちら上だから家や世界大会へということで植えた
エンジェルス
なんと
世界大会出場できたんです
まあの順番でが10位なんですけどもこれでもすごい快挙だと思いませんか
これはですね夢新聞を変えたから
叶えたわけではないと思います
当然みんなの力や努力そういった者が報われたと思います
ですが
ひょっとしたら夢新聞が何かのきっかけになった可能性はありますよね
先ほどの3つの力をひょっとしたら使い来ましたかもしれません
強制一ね皆さんに上田演説のように夢をかなえてほしいなと思います
最後リンコレ
次は
あなたが夢夜夢を叶える番です今日はどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]